israel podría ser el primer país en
dejar atrás las típicas imágenes del
confinamiento con apenas 9 millones de
habitantes casi 3 millones han recibido
al menos una dosis y de ellos la mitad
también recibió la segunda algo que ha
hecho que las imágenes de fiestas
vuelvan y que los jóvenes estén
empezando a vacunarse ya que hace poco
vine aquí para vacunarme estudio en
bachillerato y es importante que
volvamos a la normalidad y nos
deshagamos de coronavirus ya que
volvamos a encontrarnos con nuestros
amigos a estudiar de forma normal y no
en su avanzado acuerdo de lópez o como
con casi 55 dosis por cada 100
habitantes la brecha que separa a israel
del resto de los países es muy grande
reino unido apenas llega a 14 bahrein a
10 y eeuu no supera las 9 el objetivo es
llegar a la inmunización colectiva en
marzo pero porque avanza tan rápido la
vacunación la explicación parece tener
dos respuestas posibles sobrecostes en
la compra de las vacunas y un contrato
preferencial con fai ser valiente que
israel es un socio prioritario a cambio
de entregar datos sanitarios a la
compañía y demostrar sus resultados a
nivel masivo y esto
parecen ser muy positivos ya que sólo el
0 015 de las personas inmunizadas con la
segunda dosis se ha contagiado ninguna
con síntomas graves
creo que lo importante no es simplemente
lo que hemos hecho por israel sino el
hecho de que israel puede servir como un
caso de prueba global real y
verdaderamente global 3 que es el caso
de israel contrasta con el de palestina
que está sufriendo una nueva ola de la
pandemia y que no puede gozar del mismo
programa de vacunación las autoridades
tienen que alcanzar por su cuenta los
acuerdos y apenas han recibido cinco mil
dosis de israel'